troops have amassed in the forests of
lithuania in recent days
but so far only for a military exercise
a unit of the german bundeswehr is
training to support nato partner
lithuania in case of attack
we have armored forces here from germany
mechanized infantry with their combat
vehicles we've also got various
reconnaissance vehicles and artillery
since the war broke out in ukraine the
bundeswehr presence in lithuania has
been ramped up once again some 900
soldiers are now stationed here
they'll be deployed to defend this
border if necessary the naaman river
separates lithuania from the russian
oblast of kaliningrad
the exclave is surrounded by the baltic
sea poland and lithuania
and it's well armed with russia's baltic
fleet stationed here
it's also believed to be a nuclear
weapons storage site
the border town of panamunya in
lithuania has grown accustomed to its
highly militarized neighbors
it fosters good relations with the
russians says mayor virginia luz and she
sincerely hopes things will stay quiet
here despite the war raging in ukraine
even if things may never be quite the
same
we used to cross the border to go
shopping before the pandemic hit
and now we're going to feel the
consequences of this war
and the russians will too
visas for kalaningrad stopped being
issued here some time ago
and hardly any trucks are passing the
checkpoint
first it was because of the covert
pandemic
now it's due to russia's invasion of
ukraine
this russian truck driver finds the
whole thing unfathomable
i was waiting around with ukrainian
truckers to cross the lithuanian border
why should we hate each other
[Applause]
kaliningrad can still be reached by air
and sea do residents there feel
threatened by nato as russian media
claims
you can tell that transiting through
lithuania takes longer than it used to
it's clear just how dire the situation
has become
many locals are showing solidarity with
ukraine
the victims of the bloody sunday of
vilnius are buried in front of the
city's gates
31 years ago soviet special forces shot
and killed 14 people demonstrating for
lithuania's independence
residents still recall the decades of
soviet rule now more vividly than ever
unlike other european countries we've
been living with this unpredictable
neighbor for a long time
it's a fact of our geographic location
you can't just
vigilance is also the order of the day
for this lithuanian security expert he
says that kaliningrad is particularly
exposed this kaliningrad region is seen
as the uh possible threat there was a
like a question if uh
kremlin or like belarus are not going to
connect cleaning rather than belarus and
disconnect the baltic countries from the
european country
that would mean war between nato and
russia as the residents of panamune are
acutely aware
luciene is visiting the town's only
russian inhabitant who was in
kaliningrad just a few days ago
believe me everyone is talking about the
war
what can i say when the higher-ups pick
a fight it's the people who bear the
brunt of it
the people of panimune are showing
solidarity
but they won't be visiting kaliningrad
anytime soon
we used to always think how great it
would be to visit the russians without
passing through the checkpoints and for
them to visit us
[Music]
instead it's as if the cold war were
back
and here on the neyman river people are
feeling its chill